following in the footsteps of many U.S
leaders before her vice president Kamala
Harris on the heavily fortified DMZ
border separating the two careers
touring the famous blue Huts of the
panman John truce village where an
Armistice signed in 1953 ended the
Korean War looking into North Korea
itself with relations soured once more
in a region of growing tensions in the
North
we see a brutal dictatorship
rampant human rights violations and an
unlawful weapons program that threatens
peace and stability
the United States
and the world seek a stable and peaceful
Korean peninsula
where the dprk is no longer a threat
Harris had come to Asia to attend the
state funeral in Tokyo of former prime
minister Shinzo Abe indicating the
importance of relations with its Ally
Japan as a counter to the growing
strength of China in Seoul she met with
President Yun sukhyol hoping for the
same level of continued cooperation for
seven decades the alliance between the
United States and the Republic of Korea
has been a linchpin of security and
prosperity
on the Korean Peninsula and in the
indo-pacific and throughout the globe
I am here to reinforce the strength of
our alliance and strengthen our work
together
the last significant U.S visit to the
DMZ was in 2019 when President Donald
Trump met with North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un at the height of their Summit
diplomacy aimed at denuclearizing the
Korean Peninsula hopes of North Korea
giving up its nuclear weapons have all
but evaporated with leader Kim Jong-un
recently enshrining in law its status as
a nuclear-armed power and South Korean
intelligence officials believe the north
has now completed preparations for
another nuclear test it would be the
first such test in five years and comes
as a U.S Naval Strike group led by the
aircraft carrier Ronald Reagan conducts
joint drills in Korean Waters again
another first in five years she leaves
the peninsula with the deepening
tensions increasingly reminiscent of
previous times Rob McBride Al Jazeera
paju South Korea